when somebody writes a book who i know
um i want them to come on this show
certainly when uh i'm a big fan of their
work and our children go to school
together for as long as they have full
disclosure all those things
the author of how to be perfect the
correct answer to every moral question
where all books can be acquired right
now man has created so many terrific
television programs including the good
place michael sure good to see you sir
so happy to be here thank you thank you
for coming here greatly appreciate it so
let's get into uh a couple of things
first before we get to the book here is
it true um were you behind the joe
morgan thing back in the day yeah uh a
couple friends of mine and i back in
early 2000's yeah
uh send each other so many texts and
emails complaining about the way that
baseball was written about and talked
about
that one of my friends dave king said we
should just start a blog so we don't
have to bother each other just every
time we see something we don't like we
write it down so we started this blog
called fire joe morgan we didn't think
very long about the title of the blog we
it was a bad i i didn't ever like the
what what we decided to call it because
he wasn't the only problem there were
many problems so we just started this
thing where every time someone said
something or wrote something stupid
about baseball we would make fun of it
and then
will leach was running dead spin at the
time and started linking to us and
suddenly this thing we went from having
eight readers a day yes which was the
four of us and then four of our friends
to like fifteen twenty 000 very quickly
and it was uh it was wild and we were
anonymous we did we decided again with
no thought we hadn't we put i can't
explain how little thought we put into
this we had we had made ourselves
anonymous and so eventually it was like
well this is weird like i feel like the
accused have a right to face their
accusers yeah so we came out and
announced who we were at the time i was
writing on the office
and i played the character moe's
on the office dwight schrute's ghoulish
beat farming cousin moes and so then all
these articles god written that was like
this sports blogger is moe's from the
office
yeah so two and two together yeah and
then that made the readership go up even
higher and it was the whole thing was
very weird so joe was emblematic is what
you're saying joe is emblematic yes the
way that he talked about baseball on the
sunday broadcast what's wrong what what
is wrong he was very doug this was right
when moneyball was changing everything
right the book had come out and people
were beginning to think that batting
average isn't a good way to analyze how
good a baseball player is there are
other stats that are better and there
was an old school crew of people who
were saying no this is the way we've
always done it i know how to i know how
to i played baseball i know how to
analyze baseball you can't tell me a
computer can't tell me blah blah blah so
there was just this division it's pretty
much gone now like we couldn't do that
blog now because now people have
generally accepted that ops is a better
stat than batting average but at the
time there was this real division
between the old school guys and the new
school guys and so it was just the old
school guys refusing to listen to reason
or so you were blogging on behalf of
metrics i was saying yes that's the way
you say that makes me think that i
wasted my life
clearly your uh your accomplishments
would uh counter that argument all right
fair enough i think you encounter that
argument so you're writing for the
office at the time yeah you were writing
for snl first that happened snl 98 2004
office was that like to be an snl back
in the day man i'll tell you man it was
great like uh and and but the word great
encompasses a lot of stuff starting with
i was miserable because i got the job
right out of college i was completely
unqualified and i sucked at it like
and this is not false modesty like i was
actively terrible
and it's a very weird place where it's
very sink or swim like you show up on
your first day nobody shows you where
the bathroom is nobody tells you how
anything works on my first day there yes
i was like so i i finally like 4 p.m
i've been there for hours and i was
suddenly i i said to a guy i knew
so what like what ha what happens like
what what am i supposed to do and he was
like well you know we write sketches and
then there's a read through on wednesday
and in a couple hours we have the you
know the the host meeting and i was like
sorry what now and he was like yeah we
go into lauren michaels office and we
pitch the host of the show
our sketch ideas for the week i had no
sketch ideas for the week i had just
started i didn't know i had to do this
so i frantically went to my office
dreamed up a couple terrible sketch
ideas and 90 minutes later we're sitting
in lauren michael's office
with samuel l jackson the most
intimidating human being on earth
and they and i was like i sat in the
corner but lauren happened to start
going around the room with like the
person just to my right so one second
after that he was like mike what do you
have and i was like here are my sketch
ideas for you mr samuel l jackson
world's most famous and intimidating
actor is this like around pulp fiction
time yeah well it would have been 04 so
it was later than that okay but but his
stature had only grown like he was only
more samuel l jackson at that point than
he had been right so that's the kind of
place it is and i was very bad at it for
a long time
eventually i like figured it out things
started to click and from that point on
i i had a great time so which get maybe
got you
where you wanted to go to your mind like
i started writing sketches i started
writing a parody of hardball with chris
matthews the old show on msnbc daryl
hammond played chris matthews that's
right
and sure he did a great chris matthews
and and at the time so this is oh 405
like a lot's going on i mean a lot's
always going on but right we were in the
middle east and you know mission
accomplished banner and all that sort of
stuff and i started to figure out um i'm
sorry wait this is way earlier than that
this is like 2001. this is like 9 11
like the the war was just beginning
right and there were people who
were um on extreme it was the beginning
of that sort of media craze of like have
one person on from the left have one
person up from the right and have them
fight they first take it was the
pre-first take politics version right
so i just started writing those sketches
with other people who where we would
have one person representing the left
one the right and then we would have one
just lunatic tracy morgan usually just
playing some lunatic who was just
screaming about something those like
once i figured out okay i kind of i'm
seeing something in the culture and i
understand how to present it and then
the job got a lot easier well i mean
michael shearer the author and writer
creator producer right here on the rich
either show we had tracy morgan on when
did we have him on guys like two months
ago when he called in
he called in and told the story about he
met lorne michaels for the first time
outside of yankee stadium sure um not
going to the game but he was scalping
tickets great and what he's selling
cocaine is what he said as well
like that's what he said right now
stopping tickets selling cocaine that's
what he was doing all of that stuff
great and what you got any good tracy he
was my office mate for my second and
third years at the show
i don't know that i ever saw him in my
office like he wasn't and by the way
that's not rare like there's some actors
on that show write a lot of stuff some
don't like it's any there's any number
of different ways you can function at
the show right but he was my office mate
and i literally never saw him but he did
give me for the first time in my life he
gave me a nickname i had never had a
nickname in my life until tracy started
calling me shoreshot sure and i was like
this is the greatest i'm so happy about
this and to this day i haven't seen him
in years but every time i see him he
goes sure shot like it's immediately
right out of his mouth that's the best
that is the best yeah that is the best
sure shot oh my god um so all right
let's get into um your book uh you sure
you don't want to talk boston sports no
i i'm getting that's how i'm getting
into it
how to be perfect the correct answer to
every moral question you have one right
chris for him right off the bat well
yeah absolutely um go for it yeah go for
it get into it go for it i will never
ever as long as i shall live
will forgive john henry
for trading mookie bets that's it that's
all i that's my morning is that
i didn't want to pay an extra 70 million
because he wanted to be paid 300 plus
you own liverpool it's like in your
couch cushion
right true or don't pay nathan
stop stop my god this is not eei for
crying out loud i got it
uh thank god it's not eei um
i here's what i'll say about this uh
your uh
all the reports where he wanted to leave
that he wasn't going to sign he wanted
to test free agency uh
and given that was it a prudent move to
trade him when they could get something
back for him possibly is it good that
you know you have verdugo as a young guy
salary controlled coming up through now
now a crucial part of the team
absolutely
all that being said i'll never forgive
him either thank you it was the wrong
moral to say it was a morally corrupt
decision to trade mookie bets if you
have mookie bets i don't care if he's
gonna leave i don't care if it's better
for the team you keep him as long as you
possibly can because he's the world's
greatest living human being and he's
also yours right like he's he's the one
that you know you saw from the minute he
first stepped on a field look we don't
know what he offered we don't know what
henry offered him at all we have no idea
he might have offered him trout plus a
dollar i don't know the point is that
you you don't ever that guy should have
played 22 years in a red sox uniform had
his number retired
and had been paid i don't care if the
team sucks for 15 years i just want to
watch that guy play for my team so you
do everything you possibly can to keep
him that's what i think then the moral
the the moral decision of this is just
doing something the right thing for your
family really just i'm angry that's
right it's not much beyond that okay and
i will never not be angry about it yeah
but certainly now that he's out there
you get a front row seat here in los
angeles that is great by the way as a
resident of los angeles i my son and i
have gone to see
dodgers play 12 times since he came out
here and it is wonderful to see him so
now this perfect thing as well i wanted
to ask you because again and then we'll
get into questions specifically that are
asked in this book here's a moral
question for you michael sure because i
know your son is a die-hard baseball kid
yeah
cooper and i
do a fantasy league together zan also
contributes right and they're asking me
when are we gonna do the fantasy
baseball draft this year and i had it i
made that look that you're giving me
right now like how do i explain a
lockout yeah to my child how do i
explain corporate greed to a
nine-year-old yeah what i'm saying like
how do i well you know what they're
trying to figure out a luxury tax like
how do like what are you like i
basically said i don't know if there's
going to be one this year and yeah
and the question comes back why and i'm
like well they're arguing over
how to be paid you know yeah i know it's
hard and you know what's really sad is
like i am watching my son lives breathe
eats baseball and basketball and
football too but baseball was his first
love and i'm watching it affect him in
real time like he's just like what the
hell like why why is this what are they
doing why can't we have baseball on on
april 1st right and i can run through
the situation about the history of the
union and kurt flood and marvin miller
and this and that he doesn't care he
wants baseball you know what i mean like
i and the labor practices that are under
scrutiny and the ownership practices are
it really makes you realize when you
explain it to a kid yes how cruel this
is of specifically the league in
ownership to not be more uh desirous of
a full season because all kids want all
baseball fans want to watch damn
baseball games on april starting april
1st you count on this sport to bring you
from april to october every year and
they're just going to deny us that and
it's driving me nuts so have you had
this conversation we will i have and
he's he just he he understands he's old
enough to have the 13. yeah he's old
enough to have the basic understanding
of like owners or greedy players were
treated unfairly for a long time it's
that quote i can't remember who it is
now said uh owners screwed us for the
first 60 years and now we're going to
screw them for the next 60 like that was
when the free agency thing happened
but regardless you can explain it all
you want the end result is there's no
baseball and it's horrifying well i got
my kids a donald fear pop-up book and
you know
you know
you know it's better than a jeffrey
kessler scratching sniff
for kids
i'm sorry you know what i mean i'm like
so done with this thing right now the
labor
because you know what's coming you know
you know that it's going to go well now
the crazy thing now is not to go too far
down this rabbit hole they're just
arguing about money my friend joe poznan
wrote about this the other day it's now
like most of the other stuff the
arbitration years and this manipulation
that that stuff's mostly either been
settled or gone away it's just money now
and that's what makes it worse to me is
like
if you're just arguing about money then
you
a collection of 30 billionaires ought to
find the money to make this go away
that's the idea yeah so uh what is the
idea of your book michael sure how to be
perfect and uh what you came up with
that right so
very good place looking cover yes it is
yeah um so it came out of the show the
good place i got to the end of that show
and i had spent five years or so reading
all this moral philosophy and all these
theories of ethics and then talking
about them with very smart people and
funny people
and taking all these ideas that are very
dense and frankly pretty boring in their
original forms and figuring out how to
put them into the mouths of people like
ted danson and kristen bell and make
them funny and palatable
and i just kind of felt like i
wanted to like
collect it all in one place like and and
i found
the understanding of these theories
to be very helpful in my own life like i
like at least now when i screw up if i
blow something
i at least know why like that which is a
very comforting thing it's like oh
here's what i did that was wrong here
and i felt like
a lot of people might enjoy knowing
theories of ethics if they didn't have
to struggle through an 18th century
german text that nobody really wants to
read so i decided to just try to make a
book that was like i'm we're at dinner
and you asked me like hey what's what
are these theories of ethics about and
i'm talking to you like a normal person
instead of an 18th century german
philosopher and so uh questions like
what um that that you're asking to i
have a couple right here can i still
enjoy great art if it was created by
terrible people that's a good one that
was the hardest chapter to write by far
i mean that's that to me is like that's
a sports fan question at its heart right
because you if you're a sports fan you
are immediately morally compromised your
team your owner stinks and has done
terrible things your the players have
done terrible things the league has done
terrible like if you're a football fan
which i know you are yes i am michael
like like
the number of like moral quandaries
you're facing every time sunday rolls
around and you turn on the game are
endless like in and the from the league
itself to the ownership i mean jerry
jones just very quietly paid some
cheerleaders two and a half million
dollars so that they wouldn't sue him
because one of the if team officials was
peeping at them like like a old-timey
pervert through some keyhole or like
taking videos of them in the locker this
is horrifying and that's far from the
only scandal the cowboys have faced and
jerry jones basically runs the league
and you can go on and on and on right so
every time you have this thing that you
love and you tune in to watch it
you can't help i think but also have
buzzing in the back of your head like is
this okay and not to mention the fact
the game itself is so violent and so
many guys have been hurt and their lives
have been ruined and we just kind of try
to forget about the blinders what's the
answer then the answer is yes you can
well then there's also
just to complete the thought there are
also
directors and actors and and artists and
whoever celebrities that we love and
that are mean a lot to us like i talk
about woody allen woody allen was key
for me in terms of my own development as
a comedy writer he made me want to be a
comedy writer and then you grow up and
you learn some really unpleasant things
about woody allen and you start to look
at his work differently so the thing i
say in the book and it's a fairly long
argument is
the only mistake i think you can really
make is trying to actually trying to
separate these two things is trying to
either ignore the problems that these
people have created or
if they really mean something to you
cutting them out of your life entirely
because that's how we develop as people
as we learn about this comedian and this
athlete means something to us and we
share experiences but i wa i watched
you know football games with my son when
he was just learning about sports and
those memories are meaningful to me
so you just kind of have to keep these
two ideas in your head at the same time
like this thing is important to me and
also it's problematic and in dividing
them is is unnatural and i think a
problematic thing and it's that's why
it's so difficult to come up with the
answer in a way and that's why the t is
awesome that's right off on the side
here for how it's how to be perfect and
then oh there's a t right there's a t
over there right there uh michael sher
here on the rich eisen show before i let
you go i want to pitch you an idea great
okay you must get pitched ideas all the
time by the way how to be perfect maybe
a better [ __ ]
you heard that i had an interesting life
all right you must get pitched all the
time like literally i got an idea for
you yeah because you're you and you
because you can make it happen you've
got deals you've got people you've got
ways to do it all right
here's here's an idea here's an idea you
tell me if you green lined this all
right it stars tom brady
okay i have to use hello right here okay
your eyes okay
it stars tom brady and as a matter of
fact he's going to be in it he agrees to
be in it this is already i'm leaning in
okay you're leaning in uh it is a story
um about four individuals who are
lifelong friends and die hard fans of
the patriots who take a life-changing
trip to the super bowl super bowl 51 is
that the one where uh it looked like uh
28 to 3 the 28-3 right yeah okay um to
see brady play
and the four people are
octogenarians it's called 80 for brady
and the people who are in it
you're the four stars who are going to
get on this road trip
here they are they are put up on the
screen lily tomlin
um it is jane fonda it is rita moreno
and sally field
[Laughter]
i mean instantaneous green light you
green light absolutely you're right
look at those four those are for the
greatest uh actors of all time
like that absolutely and brady's i
assume playing tom brady john brady he
plays tom brady yes yes so what so
what's the processing he's producing it
so you get to meet him you get to hang
with him i mean
absolutely green light this that sounds
hilarious i was so much less terrible an
idea than it when i heard that tom brady
was gonna be a movie
so right away we're doing well but those
rita moreno and lily you wouldn't
greenlight a movie with rita moreno and
lily tomlin and jane fonda no i i i
totally would and and it doesn't involve
i guess you know these alien eggs then
they jump into a pool together and feel
young again like it's not that but look
if you told me that tom brady was going
to be in a movie where he played like
secret agent you know jack mclean or
something and it was saving whatever i
would say no absolutely no he's gonna be
terrible yeah he's playing tom brady he
knows he knows how to do that well we've
seen ted too right so he's done that
before entourage he's been in okay so
he's had a history of doing that by the
way hosted snl after i was gone and was
super funny it's tom brady's falafel
city i'll never forget that that that's
kid that's good very good so i don't
know i think i'm just caught off guard
that the four people i thought we'd see
him with next if anything would have
been godwin evans fournette and aryans
and gronk not fonda
tomlin field and mourinho and moreno you
know i mean that but that's what makes
it a good idea that's unexpected right
you're gonna go see that movie i'm gonna
you and i are gonna go you are never
gonna go together
opening night i don't know if that's a
quad one win sir i don't know if that's
a question that's a quad one idea right
there i'm i'm all in on this
because anybody who pitches you i got
brady he's going to star in it he's
going to be no that's where i'm like
goodbye
yeah yeah it's the addition of four of
the greatest female actresses of all
time if and brady playing brady like the
one thing you know he knows how to do is
be tom brady like how is that bad this
is this is a great idea who's who do you
cast as belichick because you got to get
him in well mark wahlberg wants to do it
he can't play wahlberg and a hoodie is
belichick he wants to do it you just get
an easter island head and you animate it
that's what it is our second easter
island references
this is too good this is too good let's
work shopping a little bit more rich
can i ask michael since we're pitching
him stuff what about his show
based on this show with danny devito
starring as the michael del tufo
character okay so i heard i heard you
talking about this backstage if you want
to do a show about four people who have
a simulcast peacock yes serious radio
show yes i'm in if the four people are
sally field rita maria lilly tomlin
they're very versatile actresses
unfortunately it appears they're not
available michael that's why i knew it
was safe to pick available because tom
brady poached him from our idea
wait so speaking of brady real quick
mike where was where did you come out on
the moral dilemma facing new england
fans the last two years about rooting
for the bucks i don't think that's a
moral dilemma at all i look tom brady
you and i have talked about this a lot
yes tom brady brought me more
sports fan joy yeah than anyone could
ever has brought any sports fan ever
like by like the quantifiable fact
and all i want for him is success and
happiness and glory i rooted for tampa
bay in the super bowl when he was in it
i wanted him to win like i i don't
understand if you it like mookie betts
leaving in his prime is one thing tom
brady leaving because he had hit a wall
with belichick in the organization or
whatever and wanted to go somewhere else
godspeed good luck i have no problem at
all i i think the more interesting
question for patriots fans is how do you
deal with spy gate to flake gate all
that stuff ah that's what the rest of
the league is we need another hour today
that didn't exist
[Music]
that's how to be perfect everybody by
chris brockman and that's why you don't
have that book
it's a leisure it's a
one-page book just ignore it just it
doesn't exist
it's not a book it's not a book it's not
even a blog about about statistics how
to be perfect the correct answer to
every moral question buy it uh where all
books are sold michael's sure good to
see you sir good to see you out of the
family for me
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here